just you know make a prayer and say look
God if this is the truth if this book is
genuinely the truth Show Me A Sign no
just ask for guidance and just open it
and just see what Allah has yeah to be
fair honestly like before like watching
your guys' debates like I didn't know
anything about Christianity I was just I
was just by by name okay I didn't even I
didn't even know we believe Jesus is
divine I didn't even know that so so you
didn't even know
that these are some of the drinks in my
fridge guys just some of them sub that
we Drink Along water and many other
things many fruits to pick from many
foods to eat from Subhan Allah what
about the people who are starving in
Gaza all around the world who do not
have food to eat how can we make these
drinks these foods go down our throat
knowing that they're starving I am
working with one charity for the food
project guys and they are 100% donation
policy charity I know the brothers who
run the charity and I have full trust in
them that the prophet P said the Muslim
is not the one when his neighbor is
hungry his stomach is fullum guys uh I
got approached by lovely Armenian
Christian how you doing I'm good and I
had the Quran in my pocket actually he
didn't see it I had it concealed and he
was like do you have a color the Quran I
was like of course I do here you go so
that's yours as a gift U so you're an
Armenian Christian yeah can you tell me
a bit about is it is it is there a
specific denomination like you I'm me an
Apostolic okay can you tell me a bit
about that like what is what's the
difference between you guys like do you
believe Jesus is divine okay so Armenian
Apostolic we branched off I believe it
was the Council of Caledon okay and uh
we're a we're a denomination of Orthodox
but we're Oriental Orthodox so we're
more closely related to Coptic
Christians um
Ethiopians and yeah so I would like the
difference in belief would be we are mop
fites so uh we believe so basically yeah
so basically we believe that Jesus his
his Divine and human nature are we can
combine them into one nature kind of
whereas whereas the diaphyses so like
Catholics Protestants Orthodox they
believe they separate yeah it's separate
to so it's fully human so you believe
the Divine and human nature can we
believe I think to be I might be I might
be wrong about this CU it's very precise
language I don't want to might what I'm
saying might be heretical so you know
but that's that's like the general idea
okay all right interesting what's your
take on it like let's obviously if I'm
not mistaken there is a bit of hostility
with Armenians towards Islam I'm
mistaken there's a bit of a history I
wouldn't say I wouldn't say Islam I
wouldn't say Islam so is it turkey
turkey and aan turkey and aan okay so
because of Islamic countries are there
any Muslim Armenians musl uh there's a
ve very very small amount but not too
many okay so let me ask you like for
example let's put all religions aside
let's put Islam aside let's put
Christianity aside what is your um
growing up yeah growing up what is your
belief before you was told
about your Christianity well I don't
know how to answer that because we we I
grew up as Christian so I didn't really
have a belief before so so so you
heavily
okay so do you do you believe Jesus to
be divine like do you like yes on on on
is it on the grounds that you been
taught that or is it on the grounds that
you like firmly believe that because I
sometimes believe there are people even
some Muslims they are taught things they
really looked into they they just
believe it and yes in Islam it might
make sense that believe in God
behind with yourself would you say that
for example um what is it is it like I
firm believe this or I was taught this I
am in bit of a like question actually I
don't a little bit of both um a little
bit of both because obviously I haven't
I haven't done much research into it I'm
trying to do it more now so like
starting from watching you and like
Muhammad hijab and then I was watching
some of the like Soo films yes so I was
watching their debates and it got me
interested in just like reading up on it
so yeah um I was more looking into like
cuz for me to be fair honestly like
before like watching your guys' debates
like I didn't know anything about
Christianity I was just I was just by by
name okay I didn't even I didn't even
know we believe God is divine I mean not
God uh Jesus is divine I didn't even
know that so so you didn't even know
that no I was I I was yeah so when was
this this was like 3 years ago maybe so
3 years ago you did not even know or did
you you did not believe Jesus no I did
not know that Jesus was God yeah and we
we were taught that Jesus is the son of
God but when for example when I was
watching your um videos and um you're
mentioning how can how can you have
three Gods Jesus father Holy Spirit yeah
I was saying but we don't believe Jesus
God and and then turns out I was wrong
we we do believe Jesus God so I looked
into the Trinity and I was doing more
research on it cuz I was I was having
doubts about that and I was trying to
find an explanation for it okay and I
was that got me to watch some of the
Christian YouTube channels cont so you
see so that's very interesting I forgot
to ask your name was it name Greg GRE
sorry Greg yeah nice meet you nice to
meet so Greg I appreciate you know
before I come here to speak going
usually I pray to God and I say oh God
please send me sincere people yeah yeah
I haven't got time for time waster you
get it even though I entertain them I'm
looking for sincere people who are
genuine to learn and I'll be honest with
you from in Islam we judge from what a
parent and I see nothing about sincerity
in you you're just genuine you're polite
you're kind you didn't come here
insulting My Religion you didn't come
insulting my Prophet you didn't come
here you know with hostility just
genuinely came say look I watch your
videos lovely Christian man who's come
here and said you know what Ali I'm a
Christian I watch this stuff and you
know I really appreciate and thank you
for coming because you know what I enjoy
this conversation the most it's genuine
and sincere anything that I might say
forgive me if it comes across anyway
forgive me so look let's something very
interesting because we believe in
something called the F in Islam f is the
innate disposition meaning your natural
original sense you know when you get a
phone and you set it to you reset it to
it's factory settings yeah we we we say
that is the F the f is basically that
you know when you said I did not know
that Jesus is God until I heard it here
you was in that state of f meaning you
was like hold on a second because the
reason you found it a bit strange is
because it could be that I did not know
we believe this simultaneously in
conjunction that hold on a second
actually Jesus Is God like a human being
yeah obviously I don't know your take on
it like I'm assuming it's about right
yeah yeah so so that that's why you know
why I say that with certainty and I'm so
sure of that because I know that any
human being for that matter when they
talk about God Almighty to believe that
he was a flesh bone like me who was born
it's far fish and it doesn't beit God's
nature now I know Christians come and
say well for God all things are possible
we as Muslims say that as well but we
say we say things that are befitting his
majesty so the reason why we say that is
because we say you know very well
internally bro that uh Greg yeah Greg
that God Jes this being God it's it's
counter logic rationality now you come
and say well God is beyond I know that
I'm talking about who God is not what he
does for example God might choose to do
a certain thing yeah now that thing
might not make sense to us but we can
say well God has a wisdom that we cannot
see he has the pixel we have the pixel
he has the picture but when it comes to
who God is we have to have certainties
in that so that's the reason why in
Islam we have I came to Islam 11 years
ago by the way yeah yeah I don't know if
you know my story I do I do yeah thank
you so the thing is this
I understood what true pure monotheism
is an adulterate which is what we have
three categories of to is the the of God
yeah is basically that we single out God
no we single out God in his lordship yes
okay so he is the one that sustains
who's created us he did not have
Muhammad Moses Jesus or any of them
besides him needing help he didn't have
the Angels or the most Supreme Angel
Angel Gabriel he himself is
self-sufficient and he created us he
sustains us he is decreed things for us
yes so we say we do not describe that
because Christians come and say in the
uh Jesus in the beginning was uh the
father no in the beginning was the word
the word was with God and the Word was
God yeah so they tried to say that Jesus
was there with God or then again cont CU
it's like I thought he was God different
story so we say no God was there alone
and he is the one that's the so
caretaker of us now the second pillar
the second thing is what which is what
this is what makes Islam unique to every
single religion on planet Earth what is
that we single out God In Worship so
when we pray we don't say in the name of
Muhammad or in the name of Moses or in
the name of Jesus or in the name of this
or that we worship God alone that's why
in our prayer we
say you alone we worship you alone we
ask for help Focus so we don't have to
go to priests to ask for forgiveness we
don't need to go to other individuals we
heavily heavily focus on what God I've
sinned I Repent to you I don't need to
go to a priest I don't need to go to
saying this and saying that and lastly
without boring you the lastly we affirm
names and attributes to him which is
what for example we cannot attribute
things to him that are humanly for
example we can't say God slept he got
tired
God was hungry why because we have the
verse in the
Quran say he is one and I believe you
believe this I'm going to say it to you
one by one and tell me if you the screen
any of them say he is one do you believe
he is one God God Almighty well we
believe that he is one okay let's let's
let's let's put our beliefs aside okay
yeah yeah let's let's put aside so let's
suppose we come across this verse yeah
it says God is one yeah I'll agree that
okay he is self-sufficient yes
he does not beget what do you mean he
does not beget he does not have a
child he does not have be beet meaning
like I understand but I'm we we refer to
Jesus
as the Son of God no like I remember
that word is used specifically with
regards to Jesus so if I'm answering
that I wouldn't know if I'm
contradicting okay good so so I don't I
we put all religions aside would you
ever believe would you ever wake up and
say you know what I believe in God but
I'm I I have to believe he has a son if
we me and you walk up on an island we
woke up and we like blood what the hell
we doing here mate yeah okay whatever it
is me and you would we ever come to the
conclusion we might come and say you
know what there must have be something
that put us here yeah what comes simple
rational logical reasoning yeah but
would we ever come together and say you
know what Greg I think God has a son you
know probably not why
because what's the need like why would
God where you get the information it has
to be an information that's given to you
but within your F the nature that I told
you about you would never come to the
conclusion of saying God God has a
daughter or God has a son I come no God
has a um a father we would never come to
those conclusions so the verse says he
does not beget nor is he begotten
meaning Mary gave birth to Jesus yeah so
Jesus was born of a woman so he has a
mother we don't believe God has a mother
and lastly there is nothing like him do
you agree yeah that again here
obviously is the Quran there's a verse
in the Quran yeah which is clearly
telling us and the Christians that let's
come to Common terms between us and you
that we worship no one but God you get
what I'm trying to say so what the Islam
is doing is saying you guys are the
people of the book you're close to us we
can marry from you we can eat from your
uh your meat you get what I'm trying to
say we can we can you can live under
Islamic rule but what would just seeing
is can we not come to Common terms that
we don't associate Partners to God and
worship him alone yeah that's what Islam
is I understand no i' I've I've I'm
although I'm not interested in perhaps
becoming a Muslim that's fine yeah of
course but I'm I'm still very much open
to to reading the books and I I like
knowledge so I like to I like to
research things I like to read things
even though I might not agree with it
that's fine okay are you open to that
Islam can be the truth
um I'd have to look into it okay so are
you open to saying that for example at
this moment in time you saying I do not
believe it but are you open to saying
there is a possibility that Islam can be
the truth I don't think I would be okay
why is
that it's it comes down to more
like the history of our country so this
is this is and by the way I can relate
to you I'm going to tell you why yeah so
uh
very much like if I was perhaps maybe if
I was like an English person it would
have be more easier for me to come to
terms with that okay you understand okay
so okay so so so I relate to you how my
dad hates Islam yeah yeah I think I've
said my dad hates Islam he hates he says
the thing that I've hate the most has
been born into my family yeah now I had
two choices to make in life number one
I'm going to please my lineage or
whatever you want to call it my
background or I'm going to look in the
mirror and lie to myself so now for me I
know know that the only one that is
truly there for me is God Almighty when
I when I was born put on this Earth to
when I die to when I'm resurrected to
when I'm questioned till I enter
Paradise or Hell God is the only one
that's there for me our parents our
siblings Etc these are individuals that
has been ascribed to us as being our
parents but on the day of judgment
nobody knows no one Allah says in the
Quran on that day a mother will running
away from the the child yeah nobody
knows nobody so what I'm saying is this
great how old are you uh 18 you're 18
you have the same Choice which is what
you can look back and say hold on a
second like the same with my people my
the background I come from they were
persecuted by
Muslims some of them were killed yes
that's why my my family members call me
traitor but the point is this those
Muslims were bad Muslims I cannot put
them into the category of the truth the
truth is the truth and that's why even
Jesus says in the Bible if you seek the
truth and the truth shall set you free
so don't let that stop you because Allah
says in the Quran are you going to
follow your forefathers knowing that
they were
wrong just because they are your
forefathers or just because go back on
look if you put God first and you say
this is the truth man like if it is the
truth like obviously do your research
and you find out imagine you find that
Islam is the truth and you say I'm not
going to follow it because I don't know
my dad might kick me out the house or I
might whatever exception for that matter
yeah yeah now in that instance obviously
with me I kept the secret from my father
yeah but the point is this bro you have
to ask yourself a question this is the
truth can I would you turn your back
knowing if Islam was the truth it was
proven to you that Islam is the truth
would you turn your back to it because
of what's happened in
Armenia there a very very complicated
question that if I was to answer I it
would be a whole another like tangent
okay do you mean by Tang do you mean
like I be have to I'd have to go and
speak about like Armenia and like uh ah
cuz we yeah here I've noticed people
aren't like British people they aren't
very patriotic Yeah in our country we'
we're very patriotic very nationalistic
like it's to the point where sometimes
we put uh we put our country above
everything else it's like worship yeah
that's a form of idol worship well not
we we wouldn't say like we put it above
God obviously not but we put it above
our family ourselves but but the thing
is if you don't put it above God and if
Islam is the truth then if you could put
God first put we put it side by side
almost oh that's that's that's
associating Partners in that sense
indirectly I'm saying if Islam is truth
and Allah is the truth if you if you
believe in your uh background that God
comes before our country then that means
all these baggage of nationalism all
this kind of stuff who comes first that
or God it have to be God could I ask you
something there was a few I have a few
uh the main concern I've heard about
because I've just been watching debat so
maybe I'm not that knowledgeable so I
hope you I hope you could answer my
questions cuz I don't want to go to them
Christians and then maybe they'll give
me some bias of that kind of so uh the
main the main issue I see is um Muhammad
being the final Prophet right yes
so I just want to understand
how because in the Quran I believe you
guys believe Jesus Is sinless Right We
believe We believe that every Prophet is
sinless every prophet like they there
are minor mistakes that they can make
Etc but this there's difference some say
they minute sins we say major sin no way
because because like in in Christianity
we believe Jesus is sinless yeah but
like the the prophets before him yeah
because the Covenant said that uh I
believe it was a covenant it said there
would be a messiah to come who would
carry on the Kingdom of Israel and so on
we believe is the Messiah yeah so so we
don't so for example the prophets before
for him they were Sinners yeah so they
we that's why we follow Jesus so for
example when I was to bring up
like uh you guys believe Jesus is you
said all prophets are sinless right they
didn't commit any major sins yeah Mary
has a chapter right in yes we have a
whole chapter of Mar in Quran okay does
what is Muhammad's um parents name oh um
it's Abdullah if I'm not mistaken and um
I forgot his mom's name okay and by the
way they both both um we believe they
are in the Hellfire they died as I know
I know I was going to ask about that so
um if Muslims believe that Muhammed is
the greatest person to ever live right
or was I he's the best man to walk to so
yeah so and we believe Mary is the one
of the best best woman to walk okay okay
so I was just going to ask how how would
you reconcile like muhammmad being the
greatest man to walk the earth and him
being like the final messenger of Allah
but his parents are in Hellfire yeah his
parents aren't mentioned as like I don't
know if they mentioned in the Quan
specifically they're not mentioned in
the Quran Mary is a
chapter and I believe that I think I
think there was a Hadith I read it it
was about how Muhammad asked Allah for
forgiveness for his parents well maybe
I'm maybe I'm mistaken it's about thef I
don't know about his parents I think it
was his mother he asked his mother Allah
for to forgive his mother for being a
dis and Allah um rejected his please yes
and I was just I was just curious if he
is the greatest man to ever walk the
earth he's the final messenger why
doesn't Allah Grant forgiveness for his
mother because the thing is the rights
of Allah over overcomes anything so here
we don't we don't worship we only love
the prophet mammad PE be upon him
because Allah has told us to Allah is
first for us we don't we don't we don't
deify Muhammad peace him I know I know
so for us is the violation that was done
was against Allah so a prophet cannot
come and ask and this shows you that he
is a true Prophet if he wasn't a true
prophet he would have say yeah my mother
and father in in heaven it shows that
the fact that he's saying that no and
not only that Abraham We Believe Abraham
his father his father again he's in a
Hellfire so what we're saying is these
things in this instance for example
shows us because why the Christians went
to exaggeration with Jesus and they made
him Divine the Jews started to degrade
him and insult him and call him his
mother and a daughter and him names yet
and a liar Islam came and said he's not
God and told the Christian he's not God
don't go to exaggeration in religion and
Allah in the Quran and we are telling
the Jews stop insulting him he is the
Messiah and he is a true prophet and
he's a mighty messenger so we are the
balance in saying listen we believe
Jesus and uh his miracles that he did by
the permission of God we believe in all
of this all we just saying is don't go
to Extremes in your belief like you said
you found out that Jesus was God before
that that concept was not even in your
mind and that shows me your f is in line
with Islam that's why in Islam we
believe every child is born a Muslim
um just another thing was um so
Muhammad's mother was she aware of
because I I believe you said those who
haven't heard the message and and if
they if they reject the message and they
heard it then they have the possibility
of going to Hell Fire but if they we
believe that so we're saying if that
they if they have entered the fire that
means they the is being established on
them the that the judgment is being
established on them now between Jesus
and Prophet Muhammad PE upon him that
Gap they they talk about those people
for example who did not hear of the
message God in Islam we do not believe
in a God that has is full of Wrath God's
mercy outweighs his anger so what that
means is anyone that hasn't truly heard
the message of Islam mentally unstable
yeah um and who's who hasn't reached the
age of puberty these people will be
tested on the day of judgment because
it's unfair to throw them in Hellfire
why do me a favor why don't you
internally let's internally like pray to
God to God I'm going to God and say that
oh like person say oh like gr give you a
sign through the Quran yeah open a
random verse yeah let's read it but
internally just you know make a prayer
and say look God if this is the truth if
this book is genuinely the truth Show Me
A Sign you know maybe internally do that
and then open a find the vers qur we can
that yeah thank you I
it can I do
this
Co huh
I'm not yet yeah yeah I'm going to
be she ask him to make Dua pray and open
the
Quran no just ask for guidance and just
open it and just see what Allah has yeah
it's powerful finally yeah so from the
beginning I'm going to read from the
beginning to verse S okay so it's B
context okay the revelation of the book
is from God and ex resulted in might and
the wise we did not create the heavens
and the Earth and what is between them
except in Truth uh for a specified term
but those who disbelieve from that from
from uh that of which they are warned
are turning away say oh Muhammad have
you considered that which you which uh
which you invoke besides God show me
what they have created on Earth yeah
which is very powerful because it's
saying that you're talking about anybody
like those gods that you're associating
tell us what they have created for
example Jesus what did Jesus create by
himself without God's power did Jesus
ever create anything like did he did he
create anything possibility did he ever
create anything from
himself no
yeah uh sorry show me what they have
created of the
earth if you should be truthful and who
is more astray and who is more astray
than the one who invokes besides go God
those who do not respond to him until
the day of resurrection and when the
people are gathered that day the day of
judgment those who were involved will be
enemies to them wow this one is deep
yeah this one here is deep you know why
it says on the day of
judgment when the people are governed on
the day of judgment we're all going to
be governed y they who were involved
will be enemies to them they will be
deniers of their worship and the verse
you said because and who and when our
verses are recited to them as clear
evidences those who disbelief say of the
truth when it came to them this is clear
magic so when we was talking about
father like you know when he talked
about for example this yeah when he was
talking about for example thank you your
father yeah or I mean family Allah
saying on that day when we are gathered
they are going to become enemies to one
another why because they're going to say
hold on a second you told me to worship
Jesus or you told me to worship this or
you me to worship that that that is what
I was saying Subhan Allah and the
disbelievers and Allah says that that
the Quran is a clear evidence the Quran
itself is a miracle for example when you
talk about Jesus's Miracles Etc yeah
when we talk about the miracles of Jesus
we cannot really verify it you cannot
come if I said you prove to me Jesus did
this miracle you can't but with the
Quran this is something you can verify
and test yourself because there are
miracles in the Quran but yeah that's
that's that's obvious all I have to say
if you have any questions real